[Music]
good afternoon
please welcome or entice good afternoon
and thank you for joining us here it is
an incredible conference so far I hope
everyone's really enjoying it if you
haven't had a chance I will strongly
encourage you to make sure you find some
time to check out all of the different
Expo spaces I happen to be a little bit
partial to the one downstairs directly
below us on the first floor there's a
really cool air cannon you can fire so
my name is Oren Teich I'm director of
product management at Google are
responsible for service so obviously
today we're gonna talk about service I
hope you guys like that stuff I've only
been at Google myself for a little over
a year been in the industry for a long
time and really my whole time been
focused on what we can do for developers
and part of why I'm so excited to be
here at Google is the opportunity that
it gives us to not just offer you a
single-point solution but offer you the
whole comprehensive thing today I'm
going to talk about a lot of different
components and what I want you to know
is it is a lot it is complicated there's
a lot of pieces and what we're trying to
do is offer a very comprehensive
solution for our customers and also keep
in mind that this is a point in time
that you know today is July 24th or
whatever of 2018 and there's gonna be
August in September and July 24th of
2019 and we're constantly iterating on
this and part of why I bring this up is
I want to hear from you as well I want
to know the feedback you have because
we're trying to build the best product
for you and so please by all means come
up send me an email I'm just my last
name at Twitter or or at Google whatever
but let us know how we can make services
successful for you as possible so you
know I think it's always important
because we're never gonna get over it to
make fun of the word first I if I could
choose any other word in the world would
not choose server I wouldn't have the
word server lists you
clearly there are many many servers that
are behind things and in fact no
surprise you know Google is one of the
biggest server companies in the world
right we make our own hardware we have
incredible data centers and I think this
is really important because it's not
just about the physical machines of
course it's about how you hook them all
up what's involved in getting them
together maintaining and operating and
it's also about the people that are
behind it right and how we how we
actually keep everything running and in
and of itself that's important and
exciting but there's another piece and I
don't know if you know this company
Veolia I they're a huge French
multinational company that used to be
part of that I think the Vivendi group
Veolia has 350,000 employees they take
care of trash electricity a lot of
municipal services across Europe across
a lot of actually in 48 countries last I
checked and I was meeting with their CIO
earlier and he said something that I
hadn't even considered before and it's
it's really struck me and making me
think quite a bit he was talking about
the importance of we live in a scarce
resource world and the reality is that
as we move more and more into computing
as we move and take advantage of our
compute more and more the resource costs
can go up and it's his argument is our
moral responsibility to use these
efficiently that the only way that we
can be really looking toward the future
and if software is eating the world
having ten a hundred a thousand times
more use of software as if we don't use
ten a hundred a thousand times more
resources in the way and their argument
is that serverless is a the way that
they're looking to do that and I think
that was really insightful you know I
don't have any stats I only heard this
today but it's something I'm gonna think
about a lot and go back and look into so
you know at the end of the day we have
these service products and I think it's
like just recap why are people we see
choosing it and what we hear all the
time right I mean this is motherhood and
apple pie right what we hear all the
time is service enhances dev
productivity it's about the operational
model right and that last one pay only
for usage is often the way it gets
reduced
of course is a fully managed security
right we of course take care of security
patches and updates for the system you
know of course you're not having to
think about servers it is in the title
but this is just one piece of the
overall puzzle and in fact it's one that
I want to expand upon a little bit more
because this is not sufficient so when
you talk about it haha
I slashed slides a few seconds ago so
we're gonna talk about why that's not
sufficient in a second but before we do
that I actually want to get deep up here
deep is the executive director from the
New York Times he's responsible for a
lot of their technical architecture deep
come on up and join me on stage hey guys
so you know I'm not sure if everyone's
aware but New York Times has been
longtime customers of ours they've been
using App Engine that are you looking at
a lot of our different products deep
maybe you could give us a quick overview
of how you use our products absolutely
so we decided to migrate from our data
centers off to the public cloud a couple
years ago and Google seemed to have a
very compelling offering especially when
it comes to abstractions that are
available to developers one of the one
of the big things was like the
serverless platform or the like or what
we knew as the app engine at the time
and of course like the offering is
expanded to two other things at this
point but we started looking at App
Engine for workloads that we wanted to
scale pretty fast a lot of the traffic
to the new york times is very spiky a
the for the first thing that we looked
at was our crossroads product our
crosswords is our highest grossing
product at this point and but so it was
a bit of a bit of a chance that we took
but like we looked at how the scaling
needs worked for our crossroads app and
what we found was like when we published
a crossword out people just like have at
it like right away they want to solve
the the the crossword then in there and
they were trying to download the
crossword and like you know solve the
puzzles online etc
and we just could not keep up with the
scaling need so we would just over
provision infrastructure for for the
crosswords app and when we started
looking at app engine and at scaling
abilities like we found that it was a
perfect fit for these spiky workloads
that we have for for the crosswords app
and and maybe for other things too like
you know Oren and I were talking about
like you know using it for our breaking
news alerts at some point where we could
like we could send out a breaking his
alert and like quickly ramp up to like
the number of requests that we wouldn't
want we would need to serve at any given
time so that was one thing that we
looked at so so app engine was was our
first major foray into application
development on GCP before that we'd been
using bigquery for a little bit like
which I've always said it was our
gateway drug into Google but yeah and on
that are you only using App Engine in
bigquery like how do you look at the
overall platform today so no we don't we
in fact use a lot of kubernetes so we
use we use gke for workloads that may
not fit the App Engine model in some
ways where we need to we need to do
something very specific that doesn't fit
the App Engine model so we we double
down on both App Engine and gke
during the cloud migration at this point
all of New York times.com runs on gke so
that's that's another thing but on the
App Engine side we have about 30
services and applications that that run
on App Engine and it's not that you just
developed for it you've also created
some incredible open source repositories
absolutely absolutely and if you go to
github.com slash New York Times or NY
Times there's a lot of open source
frameworks that are available to people
to to go look at and like some of them
also built around App Engine as well
yeah all right well thank you deep I
really appreciate it well thank you so
much foreign all right yeah thanks
[Applause]
don't open the water so you know
obviously we have other customers New
York Times is just one of them here's
some others that I really enjoyed
hearing some quotes from I'm not gonna
read you the quotes you can do that on
your own I will call out in that upper
left corner the smart parking one
there's a fantastic session that's
coming up later held by Morgan Holloman
he's gonna be talking about doing more
with less and serverless events and he's
featuring the architecture of what smart
parking is done it's really really
interesting to see not just how people
are using server lists for the
operational benefits but also for
programming benefits because obviously
as you decompose your application into
small pieces as you move into
event-driven workloads
you can start to think about how you do
your computing differently and smart
parking is a company that's built
entirely around this concept and it's
really remarkable to see this collection
of Sarov of IOT devices that are sending
signals out across an entire city and
how they aggregate that for parking
needs so I'd strongly encourage you to
take a look at that session and that's
that's really a good segue into you know
even without understanding the
operational benefits that we get there's
not let's not be fooling ourselves
writing software is still very very hard
and something we hear from our customers
all the time is they come to Google
because they don't want to be in the
infrastructure business in fact Nick
who's speaking right now at the same
time Nick Rockwell the CTO of the nerve
times we were having a meeting a few
months back in New York and he put it
really you know he just said flat out
New York Times is a news business Google
is the infrastructure business and
that's the core value prop of course of
why people come to us into GCP but
there's another part of this too right
how can we help you
not just solve the infrastructure but
solve the application development
problem and I think this to me is one of
the most exciting pieces about service
is it gives us an opportunity to start
to revisit a lot of the core things that
were done before hey maybe we don't need
to have IP based security for example
maybe we can start to reimagine and re
architect things for a more modern world
and so part of it is how can we take all
these different pieces which
historically you've had to think about
right oh what's the honoring solution do
i we use
how am I going to configure my
working all the pieces and you know
frankly this slide is on the lower end
of what the boxes look like I've seen
versions of this slide which literally
have 10 20 30 more boxes than this and
we want you to just be able to focus on
building that application and so instead
so you know I showed this slide earlier
and we talked about the operational
model and I would actually say that
server list is made up of two things and
I talk about this all the time right now
there's the operational model which I
think we all understand but equally
important is the programming model and
by the programming model I mean of
course that it's giving a service based
you know we can argue about the value of
modulus versus micro-services and I'd be
happy to do that by the way short answer
there is no one right answer and chances
are you should start with a model with
but anyway you know you're still gonna
have a services based an ecosystem right
you're gonna be using things most likely
like bigquery or a Redis or a memcache
you're gonna have a whole set of
services around event-driven is
incredibly important in this right and
what I love about event-driven
architecture is your shifting who has to
do a lot of that hard lifting instead of
you having to wire up all the components
you let the infrastructure provider us
do it and of course it has to be open
and we're going to talk about this some
more you may have seen some of the
announcements that came out but one of
the catches historically has been if you
buy into a programming model you're
stuck with that programming model and we
want to make it possible so that you can
take all advantage of these taking
advantage of all these characteristics
and do it anywhere you want we think
you're gonna do it on GCP because we
think we have the best operational model
but we're not going to force you to be
there so we're going to talk about that
in quite some detail now I talked about
services right and another way we can
sum someone I don't remember a year ago
I saw on Twitter someone said that maybe
we shouldn't have called it service we
should have called it service full and I
agree with that because you know of
course there's compute right the ability
to run some cycles but the reality is
it's all the services around it that
really make it useful and just as a
thought exercise you know how useful is
something if you can't store any data or
have a cache right it's it's awfully
hard sometimes to do anything of any
kind of scale there so all these pieces
you know Google has been in this
business for a long time and we do have
all these pieces
given that I only have 37 minutes left I
am NOT going to talk about all these
pieces as much as I'd love to and
there's been some amazing announcements
that we've had out there today that
we're not even gonna talk about so for
example in that lower left corner of
cloud datastore there's a whole new
product called cloud fire store it's
incredibly scalable it's built on a high
high scalability back-end it has the
same API is available for datastore and
now you get just a bigger better product
so that that's something we announced
today available for GCP the list of
things I'm not going to talk about is
longer than what I am gonna talk about
but I want you to know that they're
there and encourage you to do some more
research what we're going to talk about
today is the middle to box middle two
sections the compute side so first app
engine you know App Engine has been
around for a long time I don't know if
you know it's been around for over 10
years it's it's a really remarkable
product it predates Google Cloud App
Engine is the og serverless it is really
incredible product you know and I think
if you're not familiar with it just a
quick recap it lets you take a nap
source code deploy it and it's kind of
exactly what you want there's no
configuration you just type g-cloud app
deploy and away you go it's scales you
know snapchat famously is on it but of
course best buy pocket gems you can see
some other customers using it and you're
only paying for your usage more or less
there's always like small caveats and
these things it is old but that's not to
say it isn't without its imperfections
so one of the biggest complaints that we
had from App Engine for years is it had
a lot of proprietary pieces so for
example if you use the Java language
there was class whitelisting you're only
certain laws of classes you can run you
couldn't take if you were in Python you
couldn't just take open source software
from out on the web and run it and I
don't know if you've noticed open source
is kind of a thing you know it's worth
noting ten years ago it wasn't right
when this came out the whole point of
App Engine is you're standing on the
shoulders of Google but what's shifted
is now we need you to be able to stand
on the shoulders of the community and so
we've been thinking about this and and
we've had we've been limited because of
the security needs right because App
Engine and the way it runs in our data
center we're letting anyone run any
arbitrary software that's a huge
security risk for you it's a huge
security risk for us if we don't manage
that correctly and so that's why
historically
and very carefully managed but you know
one thing Google definitely has is some
smart engineers and so for many years
now we've been working quietly in the
background on a project that we
announced a cube con called G visor and
G visor was specifically designed to
address this problem
so what G visor is designed to do and G
visor is an open-source project as well
that you can find out we announced that
a cube con but G visor is designed to
give you the security you'd expect from
a virtual machine but with the
performance characteristics you'd expect
from a container and so you know there's
it's yeah it's cool it's you know
implemented in user space so it's highly
secure it's written and go because go
and and and but it's it's really been
remarkable and and what we do is we
actually implement the system calls
intercept them and then because we're
intercepting and we can inspect
everything that's going on we know
exactly what's going on we can make sure
there's no security issues and because
it's go we have memory and typesafe
constructs in place so this is now
what's underpinning many products at
Google especially all of our service
products moving forward and this is
what's enabling us to do everything that
I'm going to talk about for the rest of
this talk so the first thing it's
enabled us is with the second-generation
runtimes so the second-generation
runtimes they're all G visor base for
app engine sorry
second gen App Engine runtimes and so
what we're doing here is we're giving
you an idiomatic dev experience right
historically you've had to learn our
llamo files we want to bring it to you
and have you do it them you know you
want to install package what's the
language say no more API restrictions
like I mentioned and frankly it's just
faster if you just do benchmarking and
so I'm really excited to announce that
coming out and rolling out in the next
30 days we will have for App Engine
standard nodejs eight Python 37 and PHP
seven all available thank you
this has been the number one request
we've had literally for years in fact
you know we of course have our bug
tracking system and and the at the top
of it has been these languages so it's
it's really people like that's what has
it taken so long and the answer is we
needed to rehaul overhaul our entire
security infrastructure this is this
runtime execution environment but now
that we've done it you know you can see
we're able to get a number of languages
in at once and it means that we can be
more committed to being up to date in
the future so next I'd like to talk
about cloud functions hopefully you've
all heard of cloud functions already
right cloud functions lets you have very
small snippets of code again it's gonna
auto scale with usage really nicely it
lets you pair them to events GCS storage
bucket upload change there's many many
different event providers you can hook
it up to and of course you have even
finer grained control of where you're
only paying where code runs so this has
been a long time coming
we've been working on cloud functions
you know quite famously it's been in
beta now for too long so thankfully as
of today it is fully GA so I'm really
excited cloud functions is now GA and
it's available as of today in four
regions you can get it in East East in
central as well as in Europe and Asia
and uniquely in the market this is
covered by the same SLA as the rest of
Google products
people always ask like why is this
taking so long what was going on you're
not only did we need to write not only
they really need to create this entirely
new infrastructure for security
sandboxing but we also need to make sure
that it was going to work in the
reliability and quality that our
customers are expecting and that you
know we I'm embarrassed it should it
should be something we were able to do
quicker but that investment takes time
and it's something that we can now stand
behind and we're very proud to make
available so today just go signup use it
it's available
there's no sign-up list there's no
nothing you need to do now that's
that's of course not all having
additional languages you know maybe we'd
all want the world to be in a knowed
world
I don't but some night so obviously
having additional languages is critical
to so this is coming back to having how
we can make the experience idiomatic to
what you and your company wants so GCF
came out with node six again rolling out
over the next 30 days we're gonna have
node H as well as Python three seven and
these are really really nice advanced
these are nice changes I want to call
out that going from one to two I don't
one of my favorite books is a book by
Igor Gama he's the guy who came up with
a can name big the Big Bang and it's a
book on math and the title just one two
three infinity and the point is you can
look at a sequence right once you go
from one to two to three that's infinity
and beyond so this would make a language
to with no date and language three with
Python so I look forward to infinity
coming soon as well but these are the
ones that we have available right now
and today getting the infrastructure in
place to support these is great these
are like I said they're rolling out in
the next thirty days they'll be
available to everyone
once the deploys are finished now that's
not an that's not all right because of
course GCF is a new product it has a lot
of new capabilities that are necessary
so the first one V PC and VPN you know
something we hear all the time and and
deep talked about this is we are not an
island no product inside of Google is an
island I what I hear time and time again
from customers is customers come to us
for the platform of GCP and what's
important is that we work well together
and you know we can't do everything from
day one we have to iterate our way there
but VPC and VPN are key issues there
right so if you're not familiar with VP
see virtual private contra actually
Virtual Private controls and the Virtual
Private Network what this lets you do is
it lets you define a network that only
for example you have your bridging your
on-prem and your into your cloud you can
control who has access to it this is
super important and we've heard for
example from people who might be running
an on-prem Cassandra
cluster and they want to trigger a
function execution with this new feature
you'll be able to do that this ties into
the next one as well which is security
controls right now if you deploy a cloud
function its public it is on the
internet someone guesses that URL they
can execute it with security controls
what we're doing is we're putting in
place I am controls using the exact same
GCP I am that let you restrict with new
roles like an invoker function who is
actually going to be able to execute
that cloud sequel direct-connect huge
use case that we hear from people of
course is you know I need to store data
so now we're you've been able to do
Direct Connect with cloud sequel this is
a fully supported path and then finally
near and dear to my heart is how do you
store those little bits of metadata
sometimes that are associated with your
app configuration other pieces so we've
introduced environment variables you
know and our take is with this with the
new languages with the GA with these
core capabilities and just for clarity
these core capabilities are in various
states many of them are coming out in
alpha so there's a URL where you can
sign up to get access to these all of
them are scheduled for this year with
these with this set we really feel like
we've now brought GCF to the place where
it was where was meant to be we have a
great ga product that I really am
excited for everyone in this room to
give a try and use now I talked about of
course events and for the sake of time
we're not gonna dive into this today
there's other sessions but one of the
things that I'm most excited about with
service is the way that you can rethink
your application architecture and if
you're not familiar with what we're
saying here really briefly if you just
think about the canonical case of a
photo upload you get a photo you need to
upload it you need to store it you want
to resize it does that upload come
through your app does your app then
decide how to store it does that and
then do you then trigger some resize the
nice thing about an event trigger system
is you just have the client whatever
that client is directly put it in GCS
bucket that GCS bucket generates a
trigger and then your code gets executed
and so you can go from a hundred a
thousand lines of code to two five ten
lines of code and you know of course GCS
is a great example but maybe sometimes
we get a little bit bored of hearing
about GCS so one of the things to note
is we have this incredible pub/sub
integration and so much of GCP is
integrated with pub
there's actually over 20 different
services that you can take advantage of
today so for example bigquery ml engine
stackdriver actually one of my favorite
use cases is you can create an alert and
stackdriver that triggers a pub/sub
event that caused a cloud function so
for example if you want to hey i've
noticed we have a failure condition
where when a machine in my data center
crashes we want to trigger something you
can do that and you can do that very
very simply and fully-managed create the
trigger and stackdriver push it through
pub/sub so these are all available with
GCF they're working great and we see in
fact a huge amount of adoption comes
through these products today
now even with everything that I've
outlined that's not enough right and
when we are out and talking to customers
what we consistently here are two
additional problems so what is
dependencies it's great that we now
support no date it's great that we now
support Python 37 but what happens if I
have some random or not so random
actually image magic or ffmpeg are the
canonical examples that come up every
single day you know I want to resize an
image I want to transcode some video and
I don't like the cut the libraries that
you've included you know historically on
a service platform the answer has been
tough or you do some crazy hoops custom
compiled binaries uploaded into the blob
things no I don't think anyone really
wants to do and of course the other one
I'm eluded to earlier is people say hey
this is great but but how do I run these
workloads elsewhere how do I make sure
that I can have the portability I'm
looking for and so to address that I
want to introduce a new concept here and
we're going to build off of this concept
to some new products so the new concept
is the service container and what's the
service container it's just a name D
scoping of container you know if you're
all familiar with containers containers
do many many things but one of the key
things they are is there's tar.gz file
of stuff right and if we define a little
bit more what has to be in that
container it gets us wonderful things so
in our case with a stateless with a
surrealist container what we're defining
them is we're going to say they're
stateless don't
right to local disk and expect it to
persist we're gonna say it's a request
response right so this isn't for
long-running six-hour 12-hour five-day
jobs but based on a you know an event
response and and let's be explicit HTTP
is of course the canonical example but
events are always an example as well
they're gonna auto scale they're gonna
have health checks so there's actually a
spec that we've published and I'll show
you the URL later so if we define and
scope these containers down one of the
benefits it gets us is we realize that
this is actually what we're doing today
with App Engine and what we're doing
with cloud functions under the hood this
is one we talked about G visor how we're
actually running things and we realize
well why don't we expose that to our
users and so what we're now I'm really
excited to announce is serve those
containers on GC f this is something
that's come coming out later this year
so it's EAP now we do have customers
using it and you can see there's a
sign-up link down at the bottom please
please sign up and the idea here is we
are going to take a container that
matches that service container spec it's
gonna be fully managed and we're just
gonna run it for you and so what you can
now do with this is maybe you just have
one small open source package you want
to install maybe you have some
proprietary binaries you don't have the
source to give us - that's fine maybe
you want to integrate this with your
workflows right people have CI CD what
we've realized is that containers are
not just the packaging format but
they're the interchange format as well
all of those things are not possible
and so what I want to do next is give
you a demo and so staring Giannini has
joined me up here on stage and we're
gonna switch over to the computer he has
so what you can see is pretty easy right
what we have here is just a docker file
there's literally nothing special about
it this is as boring a docker file as
one could ever hope to have in their
life and you can see though that in the
docker file we just installed with
apt-get one additional package this is
an open source 3d rendering package this
is not something you've ever been able
to do with service before you're like oh
I want a 3d render some image and have
it be horizontally scalable and fully
managed and you've been out of luck well
now you just specify in here and then
you build it Google has you know you can
build it locally you can build it with
Google cloud build we don't care it's
just a docker image we've already built
it right
so we're taking advantage of the fact
that it's already up it's running on our
container registry Google container
registry don't care where runs
particularly and what staring is now
gonna do is he just get hit enter and
he's gonna deploy it and what I want you
to note is he's using the same command
g-cloud functions deploy he's just added
the dash dash image if he left off the
dash dash an image it would just be
expecting source code and building it
but in this case we're like no no let's
let's give you that docker image and
again like I said there's nothing
special about this docker image this
takes about 30 to 45 seconds to to run
it is an EAP I promise it'll get faster
but now what you can see is this is
running live I mean if anyone's able to
get that URL and copy it you'll see it
yourself and you'll notice that what we
have here is we're actually using this
open source package to 3d render in not
quite real-time but pretty darn fast if
it's not cached it usually takes about
half a second and it just renders some
text now we're not the best designers in
the world this doesn't look like the
most amazing thing but what we have here
is literally something I don't think
we've ever been able to do before which
is we've been able to take a cloud
function have a custom piece of software
installed into it and have that run with
all of the experience that you'd be used
to the same commands and everything
Sterns going to stay up here and join me
on stage for a little bit more but we're
gonna switch back to the slides for just
a few seconds because this is now point
number two so remember I said point
number one the blocker that we hear from
people is that they're concerned about
the ability to run arbitrary additional
dependencies so we just showed you that
point number two is that he asked about
consistency and one of the things we
hear is hey you know for whatever reason
good bad ugly we want to run things on
Prem and there are some really good use
cases by the way one of my favorites you
know is a one of our big customers is a
oil management oil services company and
they have giant oil rigs in the middle
of the ocean and it turns out that oil
rigs don't have good bandwidth and they
generate terabytes of data off of these
oil rigs and they want to be able to
process these data and so they've
installed or the process of installing
kubernetes clusters onto oil rigs
because you just can't get a terabyte of
data a day off
a-actually I'm sorry they're in
petabytes uh petabytes a week so you
just can't it's literally impossible
like I guess you'd send helicopters
right so in their case they can do all
this processing on-site but what they
keep in saying is yeah but we don't
wanna have to write different code for
all of our you know 90% of the time when
we're running it in the cloud this is
great what do we do when we have our
on-prem needs and as you may have seen
actually in this room just before an
hour ago
opponent and we're talking about our
kubernetes story and they announced our
gke on Prem so GK on Prem is a package
distribution that allows you to fully
get a fully managed installation GK
running in your own data center and this
directly addresses one of the biggest
concerns that our customers have how can
we have the same environment that runs
in the cloud and in our data center and
so we're taking that one step further as
well in collaboration with them and what
we're doing is we're introducing a new
add-on so the gke serverless add-on
takes the exact same api that we
expressed and showed you before and now
lets you deploy these same exact
workloads on to gke again there's a
sign-up link you know take note of that
well we can share this later but if
you're interested in participating in
this please do take a look and sign up
for it and the idea here is actually
let's show not to-- so the idea here is
exactly what we showed before
so let's actually do a demo so if we're
gonna go back to stern so here's we're
gonna do now we're gonna make no changes
except to the command line so starin is
going to deploy the exact same function
right the same image instead of using G
cloud function deploy we do have a noose
namespace those G cloud service deploy
and instead a and we need to add one
more additional piece of information of
course because now we're targeting a
cluster it's not just this world
spanning Google cloud we need to say
which specific cluster we want to go to
so he's gonna deploy it to his very
aptly named my cluster and away we'll go
I want you to note that this is using
the same command right it's a g-cloud
command it's the same experience you're
used to and a way this is gonna deploy
this one actually takes about 15 seconds
it's actually faster and
to deploy to this and so right now
what's going on we are spinning up a new
service in gke so this is running in a
kubernetes cluster and if you've managed
kubernetes before you know that getting
a service running there's a lot of yamo
there's a lot of configuration and
that's the power of kubernetes that's
why you want it oftentimes but as a
developer sometimes you don't right
sometimes you don't need all that and in
fact all of those sharp edges can cut
you and so what we want to give you here
is the experience of just simply
deploying and so you'll see the URL is
different this is now live demo this is
actually running on a kubernetes cluster
and you know it's the exact same code we
have had to make absolutely no changes
of any kind it's actually even worth
noting that this cluster is provisioned
with really beefy big instances so we
happen to be doing these 3d computation
it runs even faster and so this points
to one of the benefits that you have you
are you know back to that model I talked
about this the programming in the
operational model you are of course
trading off some of the operational
model no this doesn't pay for usage it's
you're running in your cluster you have
to manage your cluster but what you do
get is the control that comes with it if
you want to run 64 core VMs you go for
it right you can do anything you want in
this case so it gives you a lot more
flexibility staring thank you very much
now it's not sufficient to simply give
you the software and have it managed you
know one of the things we hear all the
time is just how important freedom of
choices right so both the I was actually
talking to this chief architect of a
huge financial services company who
being a financial services company won't
let me use their name on stage I was
talking to him a few months ago and they
have a giant kubernetes cluster nothing
about GK they have a giant kubernetes
cluster that they do for further
financial analysis right now and they're
explicitly saying but but I have they
have them over ten thousand people who
had considered developers inside of
their company and they're saying how do
I enable this developer productivity in
the clusters that we already have and we
hear this all the time people saying
this is great but we live in a
heterogeneous world it's not sufficient
that you like it's great that you have
the best thing on GCP how can we use
everything at once and so I'm really
excited to bring all this together by
introducing to you a new project it's
called K native this is and someone's
excited this is a new open source
project it's created by Google but done
in conjunction with a huge number of
partners and the whole point of K native
was to bring the building blocks of
service together and to give you this
workload portability so K native is made
up of write like I said it's built on
top of crewmen it is it's about
portability and its key primitives so
specifically today K native has three
primitives built into it it has built so
what you can do with build is take
source code and actually get a container
because by the way even though it was
easy to build a container I don't want
to deal with containers myself so we
build that serving right that piece that
starin just showed you where he types G
cloud service deployed that's what
serving does there's nothing you need to
worry about right there's none of the
configuration pieces and then we're not
even demoing this today but event
binding right how do you have a standard
mechanism binding to events and making
those available now this is not you know
if we just did this by ourselves I think
that'd be interesting but ultimately our
all right ultimately our goal is to
bring the service world together around
this and so from that perspective we've
been working with a large number of
partners for many many months on this sa
p you know s AP IBM pivotal Red Hat and
many many others in fact if you searched
Twitter for K native today you'll see a
pretty remarkable stream of blog posts
of announcements of companies announcing
the strategies behind this and it's
something our hope our aspiration our
goal here is to enable a whole
flourishing ecosystem of service
products to come out but to enable those
in a compatible portable way so that as
a developer you can take advantage of
the great service ID concepts but also
take advantage of the specific pieces
that each company is going to provide so
to that point I'd love to bring up one
of our partners so Michael if you
wouldn't mind joining me Michael winter
guest is from sa P come on up and we've
been working with s ap now for quite
some time on this in fact the whole
front row is sa P by the way and I
suspect there's more of them out there
so we're all very excited Michael thank
you
so Michael tell me a little bit about
why is IP was interested in K native and
what got you up here yes okay native and
I'm responsible for the SP cloud
platform so that is our enterprise
platform as a service offering so it's
all around open source frameworks we are
for example Cuban a days we have cloud
foundry in and keh keh native and solar
is computing brings us the possibility
to ease the whole development of our
business services and business
applications for instance our developers
are telling us hey it's great that you
have all the nice frameworks but here's
my code just run it right so that is a
paradigm our developers have in mind and
therefore serve us with the idea to hide
all the complexity of server
infrastructure networking storage paper
use auto scaling that's really great and
brings a lot of capabilities to our
application folks and with cannon if
you're adding a lot of more capabilities
as you said already before here's my
code create a docker image out of it
register that in a docker registry
deployed on kubernetes and also bringing
then the inventing stuff inside that is
key for our customers and partners in
order to create business services and
enterprise great applications and you're
not just looking at using it as a
integration or peace but you're actually
building your own product on top of it
as well right exactly and I'm super
excited today that we announce in the
morning the first open source lighthouse
project on key native our project kima
so kudos to our C for Hana guys sitting
here in the front so what is Kumar all
about and please have a look it's on
github github slash key myrrh - project
dot io so it's an extension factory for
or digital core so maybe you know it s
AP we're adopting a bite model RT so
that's nothing what we have invented but
it's coming from Gartner and IDC
they shape there's two years ago so we
have our digital core so big enterprise
resource planning systems we have that's
our mode one environment
so where the customers are running their
day-to-day business but on the other
hand our customers will also like to see
hey I would like to get innovations like
IOT a blockchain machine learning all of
those capabilities also in their mode
one environment and therefore we say
that sa P it makes sense to have an
innovation platform or a so-called sa P
cloud platform where we are running the
complete innovation stack on top and ki
mer is sitting on top of the s AP cloud
platform and is the glue code behind the
mode one at the mo to environment
allowing you to create extensions to
your mode and one environment so that
you can run all the nice machine
learning page features next to your mode
one system without disrupting them so
that is our approach and then I hear
from customers all the time that one of
the I think the confusions that comes up
around services they think it's just
about Greenfield right and they're just
gonna and I like but I can't rip and
replace everything III have an essay
pieces are you get it and of course
we're not gonna replace your s AP
existing European o world in which
anyone will want to do that but how do I
extend it how do I do the new
development right yeah and I think
that's what kima is all about exactly so
a nice example is when you have for
example a commercial system coming from
a cpu and and an order gets created or a
new shopping cart gets created you would
like to create an extension so you would
like to get functions which type it
connects to this event or in order gets
created in our mode one environment but
behind you have the machine learning
capabilities and you can bring in those
capabilities without changing your mode
one environment and that is the key
benefit we are getting out of Canada and
keema yeah I I gotta say like it's
literally what every customer I know
asks for and I'm just so excited that
you were able to join us and that you're
able to participate thank you thank you
[Applause]
so I would strongly encourage you to try
que native it's it's early days there's
lots of people building on it in case
you were wondering que native is not
designed for the end-user it's designed
to be the infrastructure pieces that
enable products to be built on top of it
kima was built on top of it we've built
our kubernetes add-on service add-on on
top of it but if you'd like to get
involved if you'd like to see what the
open-source is looking like if you want
to see how we're doing scale to zero on
a kubernetes cluster go take a look and
see what we're doing so this is the last
slide today and what I wanted to do is
give you a quick overview of what we
talked about including some of the
things we didn't talk about so when we
talk about service right now of course
there's App Engine right and in a recap
with App Engine it's faster it's open we
have the popular languages with more
coming constantly and I didn't even have
a chance to talk about by the way it's
HIPAA compliant it's been HIPAA
compliant now just as of a few months
ago and so we're starting we're signing
bas or seeing more and more customers do
incredible things with it on cloud
functions we have of courses G a new
regions the new languages and these
capabilities I didn't even talk about
scaling controls by the way you know one
of the things that comes up quite often
is you can have a cloud function you're
doing resource pooling you don't want to
have you don't want to have one function
star of the database if it gets scaled
up really high so how do you actually
set some limits around what this looks
like right and what you can see is we're
moving from the basic enablement
capabilities to what does it really look
like when I have a thousands 50
functions when I have complex systems we
talked about service containers and the
ways that we're expressing that through
GCF coming soon through the service
add-on and through K native and I didn't
even have a chance to talk about the
green gear but I'm gonna give it a few
brief moments I just want to call out
that we're also taking a lot of the
services that have been built into App
Engine historically and we're making
them first-class citizens within all of
cloud so you know schedule
cron in the cloud it's like how boring
is that it turns out it's actually
really really important I was just
talking to a customer two days ago who's
just like I just want to run something
once every 24 hours help that's really
you know its standard use case maybe
it's every five minutes every 24 hours
so cloud scheduler enables you to do
that and that's coming out later this
year
cloud tasks task queues was a built-in
system into App Engine cloud tasks is a
mechanism of doing inter process
communication so if you want to fire off
one thing to another and you need a
place to store them in between that's
what cloud tasks does and I already
mentioned cloud firestore so all of
these make up what we think of a service
and they're just the first step and
there's something we're really excited
about what you might be building where
you might be going and I hope I hope
that you're excited about this they're
going to go to some of the other
sessions and then you're gonna try our
products out thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]